des fans les coureurs ont donc tous mais
infidèle comme celui là seul richard
virenque
vous êtes en avoir les recharges fut
donnée hier à calais j'ai pas pu vous
approchez il éclaire sur les camions sur
la route
virenque fait partie du paysage
magnifique et ça c'est moi avec richard
c'est au tour de romandie là c'était
bien et mal aux dents là par tous les
fidèles attendent un exploit c'est vrai
que pour moi c'est quelque chose
aujourd'hui le voir avec le maillot et
d'amour qui sort de leur regard leur
parole et il ya quelque chose il ya
quelque chose qui s'est créé avec
beaucoup de personnes et je crois que ça
on n'en aura jamais